also es wird zeit für lockerung oder
lockerungs perspektiven zumindest und
das ist ja bisher unterlassen worden
sondern wir hangeln uns von locker und
so locker und für die wir immer neue
namen erfinden also wir hatten den lock
downlight werden in wellenbrecher locker
und wer hat den harten locker und jetzt
haben wir den mega lockdown die
kreativität die wir bei den namen für
den look down haben die würde ich mir
wünschen bei ideen für eröffnungs
perspektiven und wir haben uns oder die
regierung hat sich ganz und gar auf
einen incidents wert fokussiert aber es
gibt viel mehr was man bedenken muss und
der lockdown ist nicht alternativlos
schauen sie in andere länder schauen sie
nach italien nach frankreich nach
österreich dort sind geschäfte offen
dort sind die schulen offen
die haben genauso wie wir die mutation
ja im moment das große argument sind
warum wir immer noch nicht lockern
können
und es hat sich gezeigt mit guten
strategien wie zum beispiel test
strategien und gute hygiene konzepten
kann man ein stück leben ermöglichen und
das wird bei uns gar nicht erst versucht
sondern wir sind locker und fixiert bei
uns ist der frisch gestaltete neue
bdi-präsident heraus warum sie haben die
diskussion natürlich auch verfolgt sie
haben lange bei siemens gearbeitet und
bayreuth und leid nun eben diesen großen
industrieverband erste ganz praktische
frage glauben sie an diese 35 der
inzidenz glauben sie der politik wenn
sie sagt wenn wir unter 35 sind wir sind
die leben plötzlich wieder auf und das
leben geht wieder los
ich glaube nicht dass diese pandemie so
eine einfache regel auf eine zahl
projiziert zulässt
ich glaube schon wir sollten nach einem
jahr ein bisschen mehr wissen eigentlich
viel mehr wissen wie die
ausbeutungsmechanismen sind wo sich
menschen anstecken und daraus ganz
gezielt maßnahmen ableiten dass nur auf
eine zahl zu verhängen zu sagen dieser
incidents wert der entscheidet über wohl
und weh übergroße regionen
ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert
wir müssen besser verstehen wie dieser
virus funktioniert wie sich menschen
anstecken wo das passiert und dann sehr
zielgerichtet maßnahmen entscheidend
nach regionen aber wahrscheinlich nicht
nur nach einer zahl
gut noch wissen wir dass viel zu wenig
immer noch leider viel zu wenig wo sich
präzise menschen anstecken wo diese
cluster entstehen
interessanterweise herr altmaier gibt es
jetzt ausgerechnet an dem wahltag am 14
märz in baden-württemberg und in
rheinland-pfalz wird gewählt einen
verkaufsoffenen sonntag
also da ist die politik dann wieder ganz
fix dabei um zu sagen könnte den wahl
volk gefallen wenn wir das haben wir
nicht das haben wir nicht in berlin
beschlossen sondern das ist sache der
länder das zu entscheiden
und ich glaube dort vor ort verantworten
können
wir wissen im augenblick nicht wie die
entwicklung ist in frankreich gab es
schon drei mal einen locker und übrigens
bei uns zum zweiten mal einen das ist
schon schwer genug für die betroffenen
und wir haben ein auf und ab der
entwicklung wir hatten traf drei wochen
lang sehr stark zurückgehenden zahlen
jetzt die letzten vier tage scheint es
zu stagnieren
ich hoffe dass das nur ein ausreißer ist
und dass es dann wieder schnell nach
unten geht denn ich habe schon ein bild
vor augen dass wir wenn's wetter wieder
schön wird ab ostern irgendwann auch
wieder außengastronomie ermöglichen
können
ich habe schon die vision dass es
möglich sein wird das ein oder andere zu
öffnen wir haben ja auch einen ersten
stufen plan festgelegt und der besagt
zunächst die schulen und die kitas wo es
verantwortbar ist dann der einzelhandel
und anschließend dann die übrigen
einrichtungen und auch die gastronomie
hier sind geht es wieder sprechen also
von visionen kann sich keiner was kaufen
es fehlt nach wie vor an konzepten wie
geöffnet werden kann
unter welchen bedingungen gleich hat
sich ende januar bewusst entschieden
nicht wieder in ein loch down zu gehen
sondern hat mit regeln und mit einer
guten test strategie und mit dem
argument es kann nicht nur auf
infektionszahlen geguckt werden sondern
man muss die gesamtlage die sozialen die
psychischen folgen
aber auch die wirtschaftlichen folgen in
die waagschale werfen und hat sich dafür
entschieden auch geschäfte wieder zu
öffnen es gibt dafür dann abends eine
ausgangssperre das ist dan brown lehmann
der im zdf liegt bei uns gibt es aber
gar nichts so und also die alternativen
wir können noch nicht so tun als ob man
einfach wieder ein schalter umlegt und
wir haben normal
aber die schritte ins normale die müssen
wir uns doch trauen zu wagen und da hat
frankreich etwas vorgemacht
italien hat es auch vor gemacht die
haben sich getraut ein regionale
konzepte zu entwickeln wir haben einen
stufenplan
in den 21 kriterien mit reinspielen die
gruppen nicht nur auf eine institut sal
die gucken auf krankenhausbetten die
gucken aber auch in der region wie ist
die infektionsrate unter dem besonders
alten und dann wird aus diesen 21
parametern ein faktor entwickelt und je
nachdem wie der liegt darf man etwas
oder darf man etwas nicht das sind
regionale unterschiede in diesem land
hier heißt das abfällig flickenteppich
aber ich glaube dass das ein weg ist
nicht alles mit einer maßnahme mit einem
wert zu bewerten sondern sich zutrauen
dinge möglich zu machen und daraus
aufzuladen ich glaube der ist dafür gut
so und damit sind wir dabei den mann der
links neben mir sitzt unbedingt auch
vorzustellen in der runde und los geht's
er hat gehandelt und nicht auf
beschlüsse gewartet klaus ruhe madsen
dänischer oberbürgermeister von rostock
hat sofort im frühjahr 2020 vor allen
anderen schulen geschlossen
kulturveranstaltungen abgesagt und
überall getestet zwischenzeitlich war
rostock ganz ohne corona fälle
heute hat die stadt eine inzidenz von
knapp 26
so gleiche frage an sie herzen die 35
soll es jetzt richten das ist die
politische vorgabe glauben sie dem
versprechen der politik dass wenn wir 1
35er incidents sieben tage incidents
erreichen dass dann die läden wieder
geöffnet werden dass es dann wieder mehr
oder weniger normaleres leben auf den
straßen gibt glauben sie den ja das wort
glauben darüber müssen wir glaube ich
einmal miteinander diskutieren
auf der einen seite ist es so dass ich
bereits schon seinerzeit im dezember
gesagt habe ich glaube am 11 januar gibt
es drei mögliche szenarien entweder sind
die zahlen gestiegen und man wird sagen
wir wollen die maßnahmen festhallen
damit es nicht weiter steigt die
maßnahmen die zahlen sind gleich
geblieben da sollte man die maßnahmen
festhalten damit sie nicht steigen
und wenn sie gefallen sind wir sollten
an die maßnahmen festhalten damit wir
das was wir erreicht haben nicht
verlieren
und jetzt ist genau jetzt ist so ein
bisschen das was ich erlebe wenn ich bin
handballtrainerin von handball mädels
und wenn die wenn nicht ein time-out
machen und ich hole die mädels ran und
sagt so wir müssen jetzt unser anders
aufstellen oder anders ausgedrückt wenn
ich immer ein time-out mache und ich sag
den mädels weiter so das mache ich
einmal beim zweiten mal raus holen sagen
weiter so dann glaube ich fangen die an
so ein bisschen skeptisch mich
anzuschauen
beim dritten mal kommen weiter so mädels
würden sie sich doch wundern wozu
brauche ich die zeit eigentlich um ein
mannschaft neu aufzustellen ich habe
auch mit einem gegner zu tun der sich
verändert haben also statt eine
defensive 6 0 muss ich vielleicht mal 1
4 und 2
also wir als mannschaft müssen anders
agieren und da bin ich mischen da wo ich
sage wo ist jetzt unsere was haben wir
aus dem ganzen gelernt in der tat ist so
dass der bürger zu mir kommt halt wir
wissen doch sowieso was das nächste
timeout und bringt und jetzt ist es
wichtig dass wir als mannschaft und
deswegen bietet rostock das ja auch an
und sagt wir sind bereit als pilot pilot
soll nicht heißen dass wir mit unseren
bürgerinnen und bürger testen wollen wir
sind jetzt froh über die niedrige zahl
sind vorsichtig da mal hatten wir das
ist weil ich sehr viele vernünftige
bürgerinnen und bürger habe eine sehr
gute verwaltung der sagen auch schon
gehört was mich aber interessiert ist
was tun sie zum beispiel wenn henry
henriette reker ihre parteilose
gleichermaßen oberbürgermeister kollegen
aus köln
wenn die das komplette gegenteil sagt
andy sagt ich finde die zehn eigentlich
anstrebenswert weil wir haben immer noch
zu hohe zahlen wir wissen dass wir in
ein exponentielles wachstum kommen
können wir haben die mutationen unsere
zahl ist leider wieder ein bisschen
geklettert heute das sagen sie der das
finde ich total wünschenswert ich finde
es sehr gut wenn wir in
unterschiedlichen regionen von rostock
auch unterschiedliche strategien
unterschiedliche regionen von
deutschland unterschiede strategien
haben also wenn ich sage ich glaube wir
sind bisher nicht immer wissen es
passiert unterwegs gewesen sondern wir
sagen die zahl gegen hoch wir machen ein
lockdown wenn wir irgendwann im lockdown
immer wo die zahlen sagen jetzt müssten
wir wieder öffnen wir wissen nicht haben
die leute sich im schuhladen infiziert
oder haben die sich in der eisdiele am
strand in warnemünde wo haben sie sich
infiziert und da sage ich jetzt brauchen
wir ein intelligentes system ein
stufenmodell wo wir menschen mit termin
in den geschäften lassen wo sie sich
digital registrieren also jetzt testen
was versuchung erzählen sie gleich noch
ein modell das machen wir auf jeder aber
also das was ich meine piloten
unterschiedlichen charakter schiedenen
stehen hat und wir würden sehen
historiker sehr erfolgreich in köln mit
ihrem modell ist herr madsen in rostock
mit seinen bürgerinnen und bürger sehr
erfolgreich und daraus weil es wird ja
die dritte vierte fünfte welle
möglicherweise geben und da brauchen wir
doch neues wissen und die antwort darf
nicht immer sein wir machen einen locker
oder wie man eben weiter so ja das wäre
schade mir schalten an dieser stelle
wild und gefährlich nach hamburg da
sitzt tina trinkwalder die eine
wundervolle textil produzentin ist tolle
mode macht mit 150 ladys wie sie sie
nennen und natürlich auch die frage
beantworten muss vielleicht erstmal für
uns alle
was hat ihnen corona eigentlich bisher
zugemutet
allen voran ganz schön viel stress weil
das natürlich so ist ein unternehmen
doch so eine krisenzeit zu führen ist
eine andere nummer als es in einer sehr
wirtschaftlich stabilen situation im
zweiten ist es so dass man um eine
unternehmung gegründet wurde für
menschen die eben auf dem ersten
arbeitsmarkt keine chance hatten damals
vor elf jahren
und das wichtigste für meine menschen
ist sicherheit das heißt meine aufgabe
ist es auch in sicherheit zu geben und
jetzt sehen wir auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich gesehen was den
menschen abhanden gekommen ist ist
sicherheit das brauchen sie so
unglaublich sehr und perspektiven und
das haben wir seit elf jahren eigentlich
ganz gut im griff und deswegen kommen
wir auch einigermaßen gut doch es nicht
leicht das war nie leicht in deutschland
ein textiler zu haben oder zu führen
aber es geht wenn man kreativ ist wenn
man zusammenhält wenn man flexibel ist
wenn man chancen erkennt wenn man nicht
guckt dass man die probleme wälzt
sondern die lösungen und da sie
produzieren unter welchen bedingungen
haben sie mit einschränkungen zu tun
gehabt braucht man sie helfen nein
keinerlei also das war für mich das
allerwichtigste niemals in kurzarbeit zu
gehen vorher gebe ich als textiler
wirklich mein aller letztes hemd weil
wie es gerade gesagt habe meine menschen
meine ladies und gentlemen brauchen
sicherheit ich kann sie nicht nach hause
schicken zu nah an einem küchentisch
sie brauchen gewisse regularien wir
haben aber bereits ende februar letzten
jahres wir waren die ersten die auch
anfragen bekommen haben ob ihr mund
nasen abdeckungen nehmen können
ende februar letzten jahres haben wir
bereits hygienemaßnahmen gemacht
ab da haben wir masken eingeführt bei
uns in unsere näherei wir haben sofort
abstände eingehalten weil wir kontakt
mit kliniken hatten et cetera wir haben
auf einem zweischichtbetrieb angefangen
obwohl wir sonst flexible arbeitszeiten
haben und so kamen wir bis jetzt ganz
ganz gut doch weil die menschen
sicherheit haben weil sie einander
vertrauen und weil wir auch eine
perspektive haben die unternehmerische
perspektive bei uns ist wir kommen
dadurch will starten da weiter wo wir
machen da weiter
und das brauchen wir jetzt
gesellschaftlich so und dann sind wir
bei der frage herr altmaier
warum ist eigentlich immer noch nicht
pläne für die lockerungen gibt
warum hat das beim letzten mal mit der
kanzlerin und den ministerpräsidenten
nicht geklappt haben sie da als
wirtschaftsminister auch furcht dass
wenn sie so etwas jetzt initiieren und
planen dass die dann verantwortlich
gemacht werden wenn es schiffe also als
wirtschaftsminister genau bin ich zwar
für die wirtschaft verantwortlich aber
als mitglied der bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit den ministerpräsidenten
auch verantwortlich für die frage von
todeszahlen und von krankheitsfällen
wir haben in deutschland sicherlich auch
fehler gemacht wer würde das nicht
machen in so einer situation aber wenn
ich mir die ganzen beispiele frankreich
italien und andere anschauen länder von
denen ich großen respekt habe prozent
mehr menschen gestorben
pro 100000 einwohner dort sind mehr
menschen erkrankt pro 100000 einwohner
und das ist ein preis den wir bisher in
deutschland nicht bereit war zu zahlen
und was so schwer ist und da bitte ich
dann auch um verständnis wenn wir
manchmal unsicher sind
die wissenschaftler können uns immer
noch nicht sagen worauf es zurück wir
haben die ganzen erfahrungen von denen
herzen gesprochen hat der einzelhandel
hat tolle konzepte habe eine große
bewunderung für die hygiene konzept im
einzelhandel trotzdem sind die
infektionen erst dann zurück gegangen
als wir auch den einzelhandel
geschlossen haben oder war es weil wir
die schulen geschlossen haben oder war
es weil wir beides gemacht haben darüber
streiten die experten und das macht es
für die politik so schwer
eindeutige entscheidungen zu treffen
unabhängig davon wie sich die
entwicklung vollzieht und über die zahl
der toten haben wir hier schon mal
diskutiert herr altmaier
die sind tatsächlich nicht irgendwie
sehr sehr schön und da hat sich niemand
mit ruhm bekleckert dass wir so viele
tote ältere menschen zu beklagen haben
und er hätte es ja wohl alternative
modelle gegeben und trotzdem jetzt
zurück zu diesen lockerungen wie haben
denn die friseure geschafft zum ersten
30 zu dürfen
sie haben in einem zeit interview gesagt
von denen haben wir nicht so viel wie
von den einzelhändlern
das ist eine sehr offene und ehrliche
antwort ist nur nicht besonders wissen
scheint die antwort war burschen groß es
war so dass die friseure genau wie alle
anderen im einzelhandel auch jene
konzepte entwickelt hatten wir haben
keine hinweise darauf ob der friseur
oder die modeboutique oder andere
ansteckende oder weniger anstecken
sind dann gab es ganz große fürsprache
von medizinern und anderen dinge sagen
um gerade ältere menschen brauchen ab
und an die möglichkeit zum friseur zu
gehen
das hat auch gesundheitliche
auswirkungen und folgen und das hat dazu
geführt dass 16 ministerpräsidenten plus
die gesamte bundesregierung dieses
experiment gewagt haben
aber natürlich werden wir sehr genau
verfolgen was daraus wird und welche
konsequenzen es war madsen hat doch
recht wird hätten wir hätten wir im
ersten lockdown den mut gehabt
differenzierte regelungen zu machen so
wie er das in rostock geschildert hat
dann wüssten wir vielleicht heute besser
was geht und was nicht geht so aber
jetzt hält herr roßmann und die phasen
fällt nicht mehr auf den stühlen
wir fragen uns erstens herausfordern
warum geht das nicht längst wissen
das ist das enttäuschende dabei dass wir
nur messen welche erkrankungsrate haben
wir wir wissen nach einem jahr noch
nicht müssen völlig wirklich sagen wo
sich die menschen ansteckt das wird das
nach einem jahr nicht verfolgen können
ist oder nur in ganz ganz wenigen fällen
verfolgen können oder segmenten
verfolgen können das finde ich wirklich
enttäuschend und das passt nicht ins 21
ja oder so vor allem diskutieren wir
doch so als ob es keine mittel gäbe ein
lock down zu konzipieren
also wir sind doch ein ganz anderer
niveaus seit frühsommer vergangenen
jahres sind schnelltests möglich und
eigentlich auch erhalt warum hat diese
bundesregierung nicht eine massen
bestellung schon im frühjahr aufgegeben
und erst mal gesagt wir möchten
millionen hunderte millionen von diesen
tests jetzt sehen wir in österreich die
auch noch eine staatliche logistik bei
der verteilung der tests haben wir haben
in einer woche 2,2 millionen schüler
getestet da sind die schulen und die
kitas offen
die am 1,5 millionen menschen um drei
noch getestet da sind jetzt leben und
friseure längst schon offen diese
möglichkeiten hätten wir doch auch
genauso wie wir dann ganz lang oder
gehofft haben jetzt ist der impfstoff da
und wir starten durch beim impfen
auch da wieder eine zwei großbritannien
hat in den vergangenen sieben tagen 3
mio
menschen games so viele haben wir noch
nicht mehr zusammengekriegt in den
vergangenen sieben wochen seit dem wir
die impfkampagne haben also es gebe
möglichkeiten und es ist nicht genutzt
worden also sich das finde ich ein
versäumnis aller politisch
verantwortlichen und diese mittel die da
sind zu nutzen um alternativen zu einem
lockout zu schaffen
hermann zum sie sind jetzt bei dem
vorstellen ihres pilotprojektes sie
würden in rostock und was versuchen
schnelltest ist tatsächlich der game
changer und die möglichkeit mit einem qr
code festzulegen wo heben sich die
menschen die nächsten zwölf stunden
bewegen dürfen
ungefähr so nah dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen hart wenn ich festlegen würde
wo die menschen ja man darf also als
erstes würde ich aufgreifen wenn der
herr minister sagt dass wir die friseure
öffnen weil das auch gut für die
gesundheit ist dass es dann sehr gut
wenn wir im bereich sport kunst kultur
dann auch sofort öffnen würden weil ich
glaube da steckt sehr viel gesundheit
drin wenn die menschen sich wieder
bewegen sportlich betätigen das wäre ja
da glaube ich wird sie sich sehr darüber
freuen und ich würde sie darin
unterstützen wenn sie in rostock wäre
dann haben sie gesagt wir wissen nicht
woher ich glaube auch das ist ein stück
wer wahrheit dass wir uns lange nicht
richtig getraut haben darüber zu reden
wo kommt eigentlich unser großes problem
mehr weil uns aber große geschehnisse
wissen wie im grunde genommen schon wo
sie waren
sie sind in alters und pflegeheimen
gewesen sie sind in privaten bereichen
gewesen aber es ist zumindest trinken
und deshalb wahrscheinlich aus rostock
das ist mein kleiner kreis in dem ich
das mein wissen herbert hier nicht
bekannt dass wir als kinder und
jugendsport ein problem hatten nicht aus
unseren einzelhandel und wir sind ein
tourismusstandort wir hatten in der tat
im sommer mehreren wochen keinen
einzigen corona fall
wir haben glaube ich im normalen jahr
2,3 millionen übernachtenden gäste in
rostock also auch in den bereich
tourismus handel haben wir kein problem
gehabt wir hatten glaube ich eine 12er
incidents als der lockdown niederkam
also
man kann mit guten konsequentes handeln
auch kontrollen also wie wollen wir dass
das sind sie haben ich habe mich jetzt
ablenken lassen von den anderen also
qr-code ja wenn sie irgendwo rein gehen
registrieren sie sich im sommer haben
die menschen geschrieben micky maus war
da telefonnummer 777 genau wenn wir
festgestellt habe wir haben ein problem
haben ja ein paar mal versucht mich im
aus anzurufen er ist nicht rangegangen
es ist also jetzt sinnvoll dass wir die
digitale werkzeuge die es gibt auch
nutzen da gibt es so was wie di luca rap
die kann man sich runterladen seine
daten eingeben selbst wenn man da micky
maus jetzt ein gibt haben wir die
handynummer dieser leute
wir können also jetzt den leuten
schreiben sie müssen dringend sich
testen lassen und das nächste richtig
schlau wenn sie 14 tage lang überall wo
sie waren sich immer ein fragen wie sie
genau sie wollten sie sind herr der
daten dürfen wir einmal überall wo sie
waren bescheid sagen in ihren
handballverein in ihrem fitnessstudio
wie auch immer zu welcher uhrzeit wo sie
genau wann wo waren und sie sagen ja
oder nein sie sind im moment also bald
sehr viel darüber gesprochen wir
datenschutz so das sind ihre daten aber
sie haben sich überall gespeichert wir
kommen an ihn ran
und jetzt kommt das was wir dass mir
ganz wichtig ist wenn wir diese
technische möglichkeit und dann können
wir tatsächlich 35 50 60 70 residenz
wohl was wollen wir eigentlich letten
begriff im bereich von die möglichkeiten
die ich in meinen gesundheitsangaben
wenn heute einer sich meldet bis ich da
alle seine kontakte durch alles ist
immer noch hin stunden das haben wir
schon jetzt ist das eindruck und dann
habe ich sofort digital alles was ich
benötige also lasst uns doch dieses
intelligente land schlauer als ein virus
sein
lasst uns zusammen wir sind
gesundheitsamt also wenn jeder von uns
ein bisschen was ein gips statt ein
mitarbeiter alles das ist ja der
wahnsinn was wir damit heben können und
ich bin überzeugt dann müssen wir über
all das was wir hier diskutieren
ich hab' weil sie nicht mehr lange reden
zwei tagen natürlich wir werden uns dass
schülerinnen und schüler von jetzt bis
pfingsten ein testangebot machen und
zwar mit richtige test tankstelle nach
möglichkeit zwei mal die woche
unfreiwillig ohne schikane werden ich
möchte muss nicht ich habe aber die
überzeugung sehr viele werden das wollen
und wir werden ich möchte gerne alle
geschäfte öffnen und zwar nach
möglichkeit mit terminvergabe nicht nur
sagen ein friseur ich glaube nicht dass
das der richtige weg ist ich werde und
wir bieten ist natürlich an anfangs nur
zweimal
wenig leute kommen den geschäften wir
sammeln die daten wir wissen was
geschieht wann wie und wo und wenn wir
viel testen können wir gegensteuern und
willkommen weg davon dass wir im rennen
total aller sondern dass wir vielleicht
einen mittelweg miteinander finden
können sie hin land hätte ich die
cluster sie fähig werden immer
feststellen nordwesten habe ich gerade
ein thema oder in der innenstadt also wo
genau habe ich das und aus wo kommt ist
und jetzt das ist ja das was für mich
dass der wirkliche game changer was wenn
die dritte vierte fünfte welle kommen es
kann doch nicht unser zukünftiges an
bord seien jetzt alle bitte zu hause
sich auf dem sofa setzen und warten
müssen wir wieder sagen wir dürfen
wieder arbeiten gehen
da werden wir diese daten benötigen und
da wünsche ich mir natürlich dass
verschiedene regionen verschiedene
ansätze in den bergen liegt auf meine
bürgerinnen und bürger aufpassen jetzt
waren den letzten tage immer testregion
da melden sich bürgerinnen bei mir sagen
lieber habe hatte ich möchte kein test
hase sein das verstehe ich auch ja
sondern wir wollen ich werde weiterhin
sorgt haben für meinen bürgerinnen und
bürger ich war der glücklichste
bürgermeister dieser welt wenn die zone
ist also niedrig bleibt in rostock wie
sie hier wie sie jetzt ist und daran
werden wir auch jeder weiter hart
kämpfen arbeiten aber ich glaube auch
dass ich meinen bürgerinnen und bürger
sagen muss sport ist wieder möglich
kultur ist wieder möglich arbeiten ging
es wieder möglich weil im grunde das
finale der wie rost wirklich gross hatte
ich finde der wichtigste aussage die uns
allen merken sollte ist nicht 35er
incidents 100 prozent von uns sind von
corona betroffen
manche sind verstorben manche haben
verwandte verloren manche verlieren
gerade ihren jobs oder ihre firma
schüler sind ihren teilweise recht auf
bildung genommen ihre soziale kontakte
wir sind alle betroffen und ich glaube
das ist eigentlich die kernaussage
müssen anfangen über die 100% zu reden
die 100 prozent mit ganz
unterschiedlichen betroffenheiten und
das ist eigentlich der weg den ich für
rostock für deutschland für hof haben
wir wünschen damit dieser frust eben
nicht und diese traurigkeit nicht so
eine grosse hundertprozentige
traurigkeit bleibt gilt es über dieses
nicht nur nachzudenken sondern sie
nehmen das jetzt in angriff
wir schalten jetzt zu katarina witt das
stichwort ist schon
gefallen natürlich bekannten
olympiasiegerin unternehmerin in potsdam
ist sie auch katarina witt hat sich bei
facebook ihren ärger ihren sohn ihren
frust um und an diesem lockdown
niedergeschrieben und die erste frage
wäre natürlich katharina was hat sie am
allermeisten gestresst oder was nervt
sie am meisten
erstmal möchte ich sagen herr madsen hat
eigentlich alles gesagt wir können
eigentlich nach hause gehen ein bitten
das ist genau der richtige weg sie haben
auch noch suchen und die nutzer also ich
würd auch ungern sehen das einfach nur
die friseure aufmachen weil dann sagt
doch das nagelstudio was kann der
friseur was ich nicht kann die haben
alle gerade was der das was die
kleinbetriebe sind haben alle wunderbare
konzepte die sie verfolgen können und
deswegen kann ich das eigentlich nur
begrüßen was herr madsen sagt und mein
facebook post mehr ist selber ein
bisschen schwindlig geworden dass danach
so viele reaktionen gekommen sind und da
ist eigentlich eher so aus der stimmung
entstanden
mir geht es natürlich eigentlich als
katarina witt sehr gut und trotzdem bin
ich auch sehr melancholisch geworden und
ich habe viele dinge einfach nicht mehr
nachvollziehen können und ich war dann
ganz berührt von all den menschen die
mir geschrieben haben und ihr herz
geöffnet haben und wirklich auch ihre
probleme geschildert haben und wie ich
dann auch gesehen habe und wie ich das
natürlich als unternehmerin mit einem
sportstudio kleines unternehmen genau
nachvollziehen kann wie das den menschen
geht die einfachere die arbeitsverbot
bekommen die nicht mehr irgendwelche
einen namen haben und aber ewig warten
auf staatliche hilfen die versprochen
worden sind einfach nicht angekommen
sind und das sagen ihres ihres
lebenswerks gebracht werden deshalb
nichts tatsächlich mit mir zu tun und
das will ich auch ganz klar stellen dass
eine bin ich als katharina und das habe
ich alles nicht zu befürchten aber ich
habe mich in die lage hinein versetzt
wie es wirklich all den unternehmern
geht
und ich habe briefe bekommen also
beziehungsweise die antworten von ob das
ein schausteller in der vierten
generation ist er sagt unsere familie
hat immer mit eigener handarbeit ihren
beruf ausgeübt und wir können einfach
nicht weitermachen und wir haben auch
keine perspektive dass der fahrlehrer
ist und die alle auch sagen wir haben
alle konzepte oder auch die hotellerie
gastronomie kleine betriebe und deswegen
kann ich herrn madsen nur recht geben
ich finde es muss ein konzept geben was
fair ist ein kleiner betrieb kann
genauso konzepte haben wie ein großer
betrieb
es müssen alle eine chance bekommen ich
glaube mittlerweile die friseure die
ducken sich weg weil sie sind die
einzigen die genannt werden die am
ersten märz auf machen können und da
gibt es sicherlich auch eine form von
solidarität dass die sich sagen ja aber
das was wir bieten können andere kleine
unternehmen genauso bieten
und ich glaube da wird so ein bisschen
die verantwortung die auch wir alle
haben wird ein bisschen untergraben auch
von der politik dass man uns zu wenig
zutraut meisterlich mal hat er wenn ihre
politik verweist natürlich darauf dass
sie hilft also solange wir nicht öffnen
können und nicht lockern können verweist
der bundeswirtschaftminister gerne auf
die wirtschaftshilfen haben sie denn das
gefühl dass die bei den richtigen
ankommen
das haben sie nicht sonst hätten sie
nicht diesen dass es hat sich halt nicht
das gefühl deswegen habe ich das als
halt auch so geschrieben dass viele
haben gar nichts bekommen nehmen sie die
solo selbstständigen die im grunde
genommen seit märz ja im grunde genommen
arbeitslos sind wir menschen haben
wirklich dadurch ein arbeitsverbot haben
sehr viel ihrer ganzen was sie aufgebaut
haben verloren und haben da auch keine
perspektiven sind einfach durchs raster
gefallen große firmen die
dementsprechende lobby in berlin haben
da sind milliarden ausgegeben worden und
für kleine unternehmen ist die hörte
einfach sehr sehr groß und wenn die
menschen schon wenn ihnen gesagt wird
bleibt zu hause
dann muss man sie aber auch wirklich
finanziell unterstützen und dann können
sie auch durchhalten ansonsten deswegen
verstehe ich dass die menschen einfach
immer mehr verzweifelt sind weil es geht
einfach um das nackte überleben
und sie sagen die menschen sollen
wenigstens ihre kosten ersetzt bekommen
wenn sie denn zu hause bleiben sollen
jetzt wird oft katharina kritisiert wer
sich da meldet und wer wiederum eben
auch die politik kritisiert denn im
corona nicht richtig ernst oder der
denkt irgendwie nur an sich sind ihnen
auch solche reaktionen begegnen ja
natürlich auch aber das habe ich ganz
klar gesagt ich bin weder kroner
verleugnen
noch bin ich gegen den lockdown aber es
sind natürlich gewisse dinge und
deswegen wie das herr madsen sagt dass
das kann ja nicht so weiter gehen also
wir wissen ja auch alle das ist eine
neue form von realität geben wird und
natürlich muss ich auch ehrlich gestehen
mich hat das gestern dann fassungslos
gemacht dieser große ausbruch in einer
eisfabrik speiseeis fabrik wo 830
menschen arbeiten
ich könnte wirklich jedem der arbeiten
darf aber da frage ich mich natürlich
und das verlange ich jetzt auch im
grunde genommen für all die kleinen
unternehmer ein schuhverkäufer der ein
ordentliches hygiene rezepte konzept hat
die sportbranche die super konzepte
haben wo in räumlichkeiten wenig
menschen trainieren können die aber
unbedingt trainieren müssen weil es
einfach gesundheitlich erst enzi l für
sie ist die kinder die sich bewegen
müssen um sport machen müssen
und da frage ich mich halt wieso kann in
einer eisfabrik gearbeitet werden also
ich möchte jetzt eigentlich mal wissen
wer geht arbeiten wo es offen welche
industrien wenn ich besonders
systemrelevante weitermachen und können
kann ein einzelhandel nicht öffnen die
dienstleistung nicht öffnen der sport
nicht öffnen wo die wahrscheinlich
bessere konzepte haben nochmal also
jeder der arbeiten darf das ist
wunderbar und kann sein geld verdienen
aber man fängt natürlich an zu schauen
wer bleibt zuhause und wenn die dann zu
hause bleiben und nicht arbeiten dürfen
dann muss man sie finanziell
unterstützen damit sie ihre kosten
tragen können klar
und dann ist jetzt endlich die
wirtschaft daran heraus worden
kann man wie kann man das erklären
können sie sich erklären warum darf die
eisfabrik arbeiten und warum gibt es
dann eine super super ansteckungen super
cluster und in wahrscheinlich auch er
lang und im programm sind die schuhläden
zu und die leute sollen nicht arbeiten
obwohl sie wahrscheinlich nur zwei
besucher hätten brutto also
gegeneinander ausspielen hilft uns nicht
weiter
und jetzt gab's da ein ausbruch und ich
bin wirklich sehr neugierig welche
verstehen im sinne von wir sind in die
mechanismen
was ist denn da schief gegangen sind da
regeln nicht eingehalten worden die
inzwischen gute praxis kann vorkommen
oder lernen wir da was neues draußen
ganz ehrlich wir haben ja im frühsommer
gelernt dass lebensmittelverarbeitung
bei acht grad
offensichtlich gefährlicher ist also bei
27 grad im freien zu sein
jetzt frage ich mich natürlich auch als
ich das gestern gelesen habe eisfabrik
oder das klingt wieder nach kyodo ist da
was schief gegangen ich frage inzwischen
wenn ich bei unternehmen bin immer darf
wissen dass baue ich im unternehmen
und da sieht man dass wir an einer
stelle relativ gute datenlage haben
nämlich was passiert in den unternehmen
und vielen stellen können betriebsärzte
das sehr genau nachverfolgen was im
unternehmen passiert allerdings bin ich
auch völlig bei frau witt während ich
arbeiten darf egal ob als mitarbeiter
als angestellter oder als
selbstständiger als selbstständiger dem
müssen wir helfen denn sonst gibt's den
oder die hinterher nicht mehr und zwar
schnell helfen halt mal darüber haben
wir uns unterhalten
der alte spruch wer schnell hilft hilft
doppelt der gilt da auch ich glaube da
können wir noch optimieren und meine
these heißt lasst uns im zweifelsfall
den leuten schnell geld geben und bei
der nächsten steuererklärung dann klären
ob sie vielleicht zu viel gekriegt haben
und dann gibt es halt eine nachzahlung
wie jemand wieder zurückzahlen
die forderungen schnell zu helfen die
völlig dabei katharina betrieb so süß
den fingern haben weil ich möchte es
natürlich nicht so stehen lassen dass
ich jetzt diejenigen die vielleicht die
branche gegeneinander aufbringt das habe
ich ja genau in meinem gar nicht gewollt
genau das unfaire wenn man jetzt
jemanden öffnen lässt und die anderen im
grunde genommen weiterhin am langen arm
verhungern lässt wo aber alle die
gleichen konzepte haben und man muss
doch ein konkretes konzept vorlegen
können 20 quadratmeter 50 quadratmeter
eine person aus der branche machen tests
machen und das ist genau der punkt es
muss eine faire regelung geben das alle
öffnen können natürlich mit wenig es
kommen weniger menschen ist es weniger
betrieb aber man muss doch gerade auch
den kleineren unternehmen den kleineren
handel die möglichkeit haben überhaupt
zu eröffnen
überhaupt für ihre kunden da zu sein die
ware auf der sie sitzen verkaufen zu
können
das geht doch alles das man termine
machen kann und deswegen ich finde dass
er jetzt ein ausspielen wenn man doch
priorisiert und andere branchen komplett
geöffnet sind arbeiten können
egal es gibt große produktionsstätten da
wird wunderbar weiter gearbeitet und es
scheint zu funktionieren
aber es sind wirklich die kleinen
betriebe die aber trotzdem ja über viele
jahre ihr steuer ihre steuern bezahlt
haben
wo es vielleicht gerade auch in summe im
schuhladen oder das kleine restaurant um
nachher da geht es darum die familie
über die runden zu bringen ihre
mitarbeiter über die runden zu bringen
dass sie ein gutes leben führen und da
geht es nicht um den letzten gewinn den
man vielleicht noch aus quetscht und
noch mehr umsatz machen sondern wirklich
einfach sie arbeiten sie zahlen ihre
steuern es geht alles in das
sozialsystem 1
und dafür ist seit einem jahr diese
ganze branche gerade wirklich vergessen
wird